[Music]
Runk stop what you're doing and go get
my special oh stop what you're doing
stop listening to this podcast is
basically what I'm saying go get my
special at chia.com it's all uh it's
called grower die and uh you can check
that out and you can check that out
before you come see me on tour because
when I'm on tour I'm doing all a whole
new hour um uh and I will be in
Philadelphia Trenton Reading
Pennsylvania Oxnard California
uh
Sacramento January 12th Brea California
I just added actually some dates there
at the club which will be fun uh January
18th and then Phoenix I'm going back to
the Celebrity Theater I love that
theater one of my favorite places to
perform come on out Phoenix January 20th
and then El Paso I'm going to be there
and then Albuquerque which we'll see
what happens there because I have a long
and historied um long and checkered
history with Albuquerque and January
anuary 27th so let's do it um and uh so
yeah go to chris.com we also got awesome
merch there the grower die merch it's
Absolut that hoodie is and I don't say
this but it's freaking sick um it's high
high quality um go toy.com anyway here
comes the next episode of
[Music]
congratulations
I see I see I see the fan isn't plugged
in I see and the reason why the fan
isn't plugged in is because I need to
have my phone plugged in so that means
that I didn't plug my phone in last
night and it also means that it's going
to be too hot in here and those are just
subsequential events that happen to
transpire this moment so look here's the
deal I didn't charge my phone last night
the reason why it was 10 p.m. and I was
absolutely Ely exhausted so I went
upstairs my wife wanted to clean the
whole place she wanted to clean the
whole house and I say really and she
says yeah and I say well okay you can
clean the whole house but what do we do
about Calvin and putting him to bed
because I am so franking tired so I said
why don't I bring up Calvin into my bed
into our bed and we go and we'll watch
some cartoons and stuff whenever you're
done cleaning the place you come up and
you put Calvin to bed right so I bring
Calvin to bed at 10:00 I put on
something like Justice Justice League
cartoons or something cute you know
something Kristen will just watch
anything with Calvin that Calvin wants
she'll be like let's watch a big climi
Pac-Man eating a bunch of you know uh
ghosts um
but I can do that for like five minutes
and then I go like this okay I have to
watch something else so I kind of find
the middle right I'm I'm I'm like hey
Calvin what do you want to watch I bring
him by the way it is late it's 10 p.m.
whatever he says I want to watch big
giant Pac-Man and I go like this how
about we just look at what's on
Paramount
[Laughter]
plus we compromise on Disney plus I turn
it on and there's like a Justice League
thing and so I put on cartoons I go boom
and he goes and he starts watching and I
go like
this pass out completely the next thing
I remember is that it
is 9:00
a.m. it's 9:00 a.m. all of a sudden I
blink and it's 9:00 a.m. yes dude he got
so much sleep it's unbelievable man it
is like dude and let me tell you
something I do this podcast always at
5:00 p.m. or 4 p.m. sometimes if I have
a lot of things to do I might do it at
like 2:00 p.m. sometimes I do it at 8:00
p.m. I get nutty
dude right now doing this podcast it is
10:30
a.m. dude I got so much sleep and the
reason why I got so much sleep is
because I changed my dude he let he let
people get to his head he let people get
to his head is what he did because I
wanted to leave look dude I don't look I
used to be the kind of guy that is just
like all right I'm going to take the
earliest flight ever so I could have my
whole day I'm going to do that if there
was a flight at 6: a.m. I took
it thank God there wasn't a flight at
4:00 a.m. cuz guess what your boy would
have took
it I always said to my travel agent
earliest one because I wanted to get
back but guess what for what what do you
need to get back for comedian guy huh
what do you need to get back for a 900
p.m. M show at the Laugh
Factory nah so I go like this wait one
day I'm just sitting by myself tired as
[__] the airport at like 4:30 a.m.
because you got to get picked up earlier
you know and Starbucks isn't even open
you know that that that uh dunin Donuts
isn't even open they're trying to
Rebrand themselves only to be Duncan but
yeah right change all the signs first
I'm not call you Duncan until you change
every single sign that you have you're
Duncan
Donuts they're not even open yet I'm at
the airport like this and I go like this
why do I why do I fly why do I fly out
why do I fly out at 5:40
a.m. I started flying out
late at least 2 p.m onward
dude guess
what I didn't get sick
anymore I didn't get sick sleep is
the remedy dude it is the remedy a
little bug might go like this
woo a little bug might be like so go a
little bug might be going oo doing tly
worlders where can I fit where can I fit
o is that that guy from is that that guy
from
undatable right on my tongue right if I
have enough sleep my sleepness goes
attack if I don't have enough sleep my
sleepness goes what's going on uh who
happened where oh there's an antib
there's a there's a there's a foreign
body oh the antibodies are just too
tired man and they go
and I get sick but
dude the other day these are my crew
okay Lulu Denny Sam Enrique we're all
traveling and it's awesome
okay Lulu and Denny go like this yo the
flight's at 5:00 p.m. that's wait no
yeah the flight's at 5:00 P p.m. that's
crazy I don't want to waste the whole
day we're going to go early so they
leave at 7:00 a.m. I go like this you
guys are going to get
sick why wow I'm crazy I go you guys are
going to get sick they go U well you
know what I'm just going to do
it so in uh Sam's like you know you want
you want to stay the whole day and guess
what because here's the thing I was in
Baltimore now before we even get into
when I took the flight let's get into
let's get into Baltimore hey Baltimore
what are
you hey Baltimore what what's going on
in your
city now let me actually start by saying
the people in Baltimore are awesome the
people in Baltimore I find to be really
I love their energy they seem cool
they're on the level but hey buildings
in Baltimore what's going on hey the
greyness in Baltimore what's going on
with you hey places that are too spread
apart that I have to walk to for
instance if I need to go to the bank
that's cool but then why is the
Starbucks nine blocks away hey Baltimore
what are you hey Baltimore have a
meeting get all your buildings close
together and stay there and that's the
city okay because guess what I don't
want to have to walk nine blocks to get
to somewhere else that's second on my
erand list because that's more time for
me to get my wig split cuz Baltimore
you're violent as [__] so maybe it's not
the problem that 's a lot of crime in
Baltimore maybe the problem is the
places are too spread
out cuz if the places were together
right who's going to rob someone near a
bunch of people right it's like hyenas
they wait for the lion to get away from
the
pride hey Baltimore you're too gray and
spaced
out so
Baltimore is the city is just so and
also it's one of those cities that has
steam coming up out of the ground like
what you know like you like where you're
like oh is this
Gotham you know like New York has that
but some places Baltimore everywhere you
turn there's just steam coming out of
the ground like like a giant is vaping
under a
hotel and and
so I get to Baltimore and I say hey man
is there a coffee shop around not like a
chain one and the guy says yeah
Starbucks is right around the corner and
I say okay uh you're not listening to
what I'm saying or you're demented is
there a different one and he was like oh
no you know what there's one in the
hotel I go in one in the hotel it's fine
it's great it's
nice and I'm there and Sam's like you
sure you don't want to leave uh tomorrow
early and I say I'll look into it and I
let Sam color my decision and I got a
flight at 7:00 a.m. and I connected in
Salt Lake City now everyone on the plane
from uh Baltimore to it like I
thought it's weird to have a direct
flight from Baltimore to Salt Lake City
like what is that you know it's like oh
you're just like I guess people here
need to get
there but they did and the plane was
blonde as [__] so they Mormon as
[__] um but I did and I didn't sleep
much and then I landed in Salt Lake City
I I I I um I fell asleep the whole
flight this is so interesting even
though it's not I fell asleep the whole
flight from Baltimore to what do you
call it salake City got the kect gang
kect gang ping ping bang and then flew
back to LAX dude and then came home was
tired as [__] the whole day dude was
tired of [__] the whole day I'm going
look at this I'm going to get sick and
I'm going to get canker stures dude some
virus is going to be spreading God damn
it I don't even have herpes but it's
going to sprout something's going to
happen dude I'm going to have not have
my whips about me I'm going to walk
outside a bus is going to hit me
something's going to go on dude my mom
used to be like eat or you're G to get
sick I swear she should have been like
sleep or you're going to get
sick so
anyway I uh I I get home play with the
kids dude it's awesome man I'm with
Billy I'm with cvin I'm with Kristen and
it's just great 10:00 I out I know I
said this already woke up it's 9: bro
let me tell you something 11 hours of
sleep let me tell you something D I
don't know what it is about people who
brag about got four hours of sleep hey
hey dude me only got two hours of sleep
last night hey hey hey me how hard do I
work only got two hours of sleep last
night and now I'm at and now I'm at the
job you know people be like hey dude
sleep is the cousin of death no sleep is
sleep death is what's going to happen if
you don't get enough of
it dude I got 11 hours of sleep and I'm
Superman okay and so the people who
don't get eight hours of I need at least
eight to nine hours of sleep if you
don't hey people who don't get that
people who don't people who do three
four hours of sleep like Brent Moren or
you know who you are out there my dad
used to do it hey people who only get a
little bit of sleep dude eight hours get
it go to bed early get it otherwise
you're gonna get dementia one day uh the
rocks always up posting I work hard uh
uh travel Lots grind doesn't stop sleep
zero dude you you will die you're one
day you're going to wake up from that
one hour
sleep from 3:00 a.m. to 4:00 a.m. and
you're just going to go like this whoa I
actually I can't smell what I can't
smell what The Rock is cooking anymore
you're going to be like where am I who
am I what plane is this you're going to
die sleep is the most important thing
and that's why I'm Invincible
dude [__] yeah man anyway man that's the
whole thing about
sleeping that's
great can't wait to be in Phoenix and El
Paso and Albuquerque and Brea and Oxnard
and Philadelphia and reading I don't
know what's up with Trenton dude that
that theater's got to get it
together I need to get started start
selling more tickets I don't know what's
going on the checkout process is
horrendous for
them like when I when people get my
tickets I want them to go to my site and
just be
[Music]
like but you
know uh so what do we have here what do
we have here
um the new Andre 3000 uh album that
sucks they have it that's
sucks hey do bars hey dude hey the
review of the Andre 3000 album is in
right now hey it
sucks do
barsy 2,000 do bars or don't do anything
I I there are these people that we get
behind that are just whatever they do
it's it's so amazing right like Kor
Reeves is one of them okay Kor Reeves
could go out take his shoes off in the
sand and just take a large dump in a
boy's sand castle and people will be
like man that can of Reeves is it's so
cool how he gives to the
community you
know
and Andre 3000 is one of those people
right people think he's a genius and I'm
like I like look his music is
fine when they came out with let's go
through the out let's go through the
outcast catalog okay let's go through
the outcast catalog out Outcast is one
of those Outcast was so big when I had
to spell Outcast really with like an the
actual word I would still do it with a K
and I'd be like wait a minute that's not
right
so that's how big they are Outcast
discography all right so let's go
through the outcast discography here um
in order right okay see now I'm pissed
because it's not in order all right
Southern playalistic whatever that one
was was great right Stankonia was I
don't oh and I was good aens was the
[__] atali was the [__] dude but here's
the deal I don't know we're not doing
the discography but
um once they got to this song like I
could handle like hey yah I could
handle right it was a a Bop once they
got to the one where they were like and
the whole world loves it when you play
that
song once it got to that
one so alcast was really good at making
songs where I was like wow all right
okay and the second song time I heard
the song I was like okay the third time
I heard the song I go all right this a
lot I don't know you know that that hey
the first time he oh [__] the second he
oh third time you're like uh this is it
really this is it huh it's just a Bop
kind of okay dude the [__] hole
in during that song I go all right in
the middle of the song I go this is the
most annoying song I've ever heard in my
life my entire life okay after the whole
world L it when you put that song ha or
whatever that song is I was done I was
done with Outcast and I go like this I
don't know if I'm really an outcast guy
big boy I could get behind Andre I don't
know if I could get behind it anymore
right then he was in a movie with Mark
Wahlberg and Garrett Hedland and I go
you know what dude I'm actually done is
it called four brothers or
something and then you didn't hear from
Andre 3000 in a while and I was like
that's dope it's cool to fade into
Oblivion I want to do
that I didn't make that money yet though
right when I make that money then I will
people are so a lot of people are mad I
still do standup comedy dude I tell you
what give me a whole bunch of money I'm
done
haters fund me
um so then he released the flute thing
and now people are just like oh it
remember when he was like traveling
around with the flute just in like new
wherever the [__] he was people like oh
this Andre did had no idea and it would
just viral videos of him playing a flute
every and everyone was like oh [__] look
at that look at this guy just walking
this walking the Earth just playing a
flute like a [__] cool dude dude
could you
imagine
like somebody you didn't like starting
to do that you'd be like this guy lost
his mind [__] him okay so anyway he came
out
with this album 103,000 is releasing his
first album in over
years
wow and look I get it you don't want to
rap anymore I think that's cool God
Bless but when guys get too rich and too
out of touch and then they're like I'm
going to pick up a flute or start
collecting old cameras they're gone
man they're gone they're gone dude
imagine being around somebody with a
flute you
know look eight these are the track
lists
um I swear I really wanted to make a rap
album but this is literally the way the
wind blew me this time that's the first
one the second track is
the slang
word I can't say it right P SS y rolls
off the tongue with a far better ease
than the proper word vagina do you agree
that's the second TR dude imagine being
in concert being
like all right here's here's here's my
next one the slang word he rolls off the
tongue with far better ease than the
proper word vagina do you
agree dude here Here Comes track three
the night in Hawaii when I turned into a
panther and started making these low
register purring tones that I couldn't
control [__] was
[Music]
wild what there's another one bipolo
disorder's daughter wears a 3,000 button
down in bured
uh
wow so um look look at this this new
Direction got the seal of approval from
friends like Tyler Creator and Frank
Ocean although Andre probably didn't
need it just he's just happy when he's
playing the flute yeah so like don't
like do I tell you if I see a comedian
all of a sudden come out with like a
rock album you
know or like they start
like doing
something that's not
comedy no I'm telling them oh yeah this
sucks dude I'm not Frank Frank oing your
[__]
if all of a sudden Eric Griffin starts
you know what I mean
painting I don't know dude future is
40 the rapper is that what you're saying
here he
is that's that's crazy I thought he was
like 30
Sensational hey
hey hey hey future it's your birthdayy
happy birthday
Sensational hey future birthday happy
birthday
Sensational when's Jay's birthday
um
wow dude I being [__] in your 40s is
so dope I and then being 30s is cool
being in your 40s is so dope it's so
dope you know you got a little bit of
gray you know and me I've been working
out so I am beefy right you seen the
latest picture on my Instagram I go what
the [__] you know what I'm saying right
and that was just a steal from a video I
go stop the video screen cap it stop the
video screen cap it dude stop the
cap don't we have that which one is it I
don't see
it hey dude stop the video stop the
cap put the video on stop the C dude I
go my shoulders go crazy right I took it
posted a few pictures of it whatever all
good I'm beef beef supreme but the deal
is 40s is where it's at and then 50s is
not really where it's at but 50 to 56 is
okay but after that bro have you seen
Hugh Jackman lately the guy got divorced
and it's like he leveled
up they're doing another Wolverine
Deadpool movie and it's like when are
they going to get a new Wolverine they
got to get a 25-year-old
Wolverine a short they got they should
do it differently like a really
short stocky
dude like how he is in the comics
um so its future is 40 and Joe Biden's
birthday so Joe Biden's got his last
birthday coming up here
um Joe Biden's birthday how old old is
Joe Biden Jesus
Christ Joe Biden age 81 so he's 81
that's just too old I mean dude he's 81
and Barack Obama is still only
62 whoa dude Barack Obama was President
when he was like
seven that was so long
ago Joe Biden is 72 yo
what is this what is this guy does a
[__] um half court shot in uh what do
you call
it dude I feel unbelievable I got 11
hours of sleep and then I woke up and I
drank that magic mine and I just go oh
it's
on what is this why won't it why won't
it load great good so
good you guys use Twitter or X still it
is is it good Elon said something I
don't I didn't look into it but people
were like oh yeah he he's a Nazi or
something cuz he said something and it's
like oh here we go bro went down from
the half court
shot oh you had the distance you had the
distance Anthony come back Anthony uhoh
he [__] himself up the
music let's get you up Anthony
you didn't get it from half court but
we're going to give you a chance
thepoint Line music dude so
disrespectful to play the
[__] look look hurts himself so bad
oh missed it so far you had the distance
you had the distance Anthony come back
Anthony uhoh the music oh dude so
disrespectful to play the ghost DJs
after that or whatever the [__] that
that's from at oh no oh he broke his
[__] femur at night I dream love you
you are to be your lady baby if your
game is on give me a combo oh my God I
can't F my legs get and make it all for
you last night oh my God we need the we
need the [__] ambulance to come at
night I dream of you who are to be your
lady baby oh my God I can't feel my
[__] leg if the beat is on me give it
all night I oh he he [__] himself dude
clear if your feelings right save it oh
for
you he [__] himself all over the metac
dude wow Calvin just said dad you're
loud from the outside Calvin am I too
loud so disrespectful dude this is how
you get so many
toys dude the music was great
um Looking Glass podcast this is from
Logan Looking Glass podcast looking
glass pod podcast suck one go to holler.
b/ christalia if you want to purchase a
10-word ad or a shout out on this
podcast dude um oh man imagine being the
guy doing the half
court how about the 10 freeway is it
back
wow the what hey dude thanks
Biden hey dude thanks thanks Obama uh um
so there was a big fire under the 10
freeway and everyone got and I honestly
I was like great the traffic is going to
be so bad the traffic's so bad dude we
were in where was I somewhere and they
were like oh sorry about the traffic I
was like man I'm from LA and they
laughed and it was it was great we we we
identified and [__] with each other but
um the 10 freeway was on fire and they
were like it's going to be closing
indefinitely and it opened back uh it
opened back up last week and that's
where he com to hear for the news so so
that happened and that's great and um
and thank God because the traffic was
going to be bad and that's okay that's
okay but this is the that that's where
you come to here for the news so that's
the news this is the news from
congratulations the 10 freeway was
closed now it's back open so anyway um
but uh it's going to be Thanksgiving it
is Thanksgiving actually it is that it's
Thanksgiving you're listening to this
podcast if you're a patreon member it's
on Wednesday you're listening to this
hello how are you but if it's uh on
YouTube it's Thursdays hello how are you
and thank and Happy Thanksgiving I if
people watch this podcast on
Thanksgiving if you're going to wait
till Friday and Thanksgiving was light
was yesterday but it's like dude let's
celebrate or let's not because it was
it's very very violent in the past you
know very violent Thanksgiving is nice
to get the family together but you know
what something my wife said and this is
so
true this is so
true why is
Thanksgiving
giving
uh uh uh
because this is I don't like tradition
we know this about congratulations right
um uh the the the 20 on the 23rd why is
it on the 23rd in 198 in 1863 prison
Abram Lincoln designate designated the
national holiday think going be the last
Thursday in November so he just
designated
it uh okay so okay so come 1938
President Roosevelt changed it to the
third Thursday November that that's
that's some like you know he wanted to
he's like nah that's some power [__] but
it wasn't very popular oh
really oh so now it's the fourth
Thursday in November Jesus Christ I mean
so all right if it's so arbitrary make
it in
June just make it or you
know in February it after Christmas dude
it's too much because everyone ends up
getting either married or having a
significant other and then you're [__]
dude right you got to go do the [__]
uh November 23rd and then a month later
you got to go do the other [__] on the
25th of December because it's Christmas
or whatever holiday you're you're
celebrating uh the Hanukkah or k Quanza
or whatever the hell it
is we all collectively or maybe it was
Abe Lincoln decided that it was just
going to be a month before Christmas hey
that sucks dude it's too hectic make it
earlier and Halloween too dude you know
what there's so many holidays all
bunched up at the end of the year and
it's every
year you're gonna go ahead and make that
[__] every year every year we're going
to be like oh got you know how many
people commit
suicide because of the the holidays it's
because they're all bunched up and then
New Year yo this is actually tripping me
out let's space this out right now first
of all I'm not even going to count the
[__] ones like
uh these are the main ones uh Christmas
Thanksgiving uh Halloween New Year's
dude October November December they're
all three months together that
sucks so we got four so here's when
they're going to be dude Christmas let's
leave it because it's the biggest one to
25th great New Year's is now March
25th
I just remember Fourth of July it's
pretty big March June July New Year is
March 25th July 4th can be July
20th so now you celebrate July 4th July
20th you can still call it 4th of July
but it's the [__] 20th because you
get 25th March April May June you get
three
then no that that was her it's fine then
you get yet
June July August September that can be
Halloween September what comes next
October November I guess thanksgiving's
[__] dude there's too
many you know what
dude get rid of I'm I don't want to do
this because it sucks but I'm American
get rid of Fourth of July which one
should we get rid of it's either
Halloween or 4th of July so you know
there's too many [__] out there that
they well the [__] go crazy on Fourth
of July too right the [__] get all
dressed up American
[__] I I think [__] more probably
they hold they hold it down they but
here's the thing though CU Halloween is
supposed to be for kids you keep
Halloween the [__] got to go crazy on
the fourth of July I just you combine
Halloween into the [__] holiday with the
kids it's not doesn't sound right but
then you leave Fourth of July out of it
all right so that's what we do and you
get or you know what we do
this is what we do you get rid of
Halloween you get rid of Fourth of July
and you just have the [__] go crazy on
Thanksgiving you get them with the
[__] you know the the Hat with the
belt on it and like just feathers over
their
titties and just like just huge stiletto
heels with like a [__] Turkey Leg
coming out of their
[__] anyone hungry just a [__] with a
[__] anyone hungry just pulling out a
a [__] something a king would eat in
the year 1700 in front of a bunch of
people like a piece of [__] just pull it
out of their nap out of their nappy
right just pull it right out of there
just right out of their fried butterfly
just right out of their Hatchet go like
this hey dude anybody hungry and then
you since you're already with the creepy
Uncle because it's Thanksgiving they go
oh I'll have
that Perfect Dude [__] up Thanksgiving
it sucks anyway it's violent as [__]
everyone murdered a bunch of Indians so
you get a bunch of [__] come out they
fix
Thanksgiving
finally it's not about the murdering and
the pillaging okay you got a bunch of
[__] with the [__] you know you get
a a [__] with an Indian headdress on and
you just some f you know some stuffing
over her tits just so disgusting
dude and just high heels pulling up
[__] some wings pulling a turkey leg
out of her here you go let's give
thanks what are you thankful for
what just that kind of
[__] I'm thankful for my girlies you
know I'm thankful for
wifey there you go dude because you
can't slit up Christmas
right dude um what do you call it um New
Year's Eve is I don't like New Year's
Eve because it's too
stressful I have a dream of going I I'll
never do this now because I have kids
and [__] in a family but
I had a dream of one
day
going on January 31st is there or sorry
December 31st is there 3 one dayss in
December
yeah driving out to the middle of
nowhere at like 10
p.m. no phone no
nothing just drive out turn the radio
off and just chill and wait
and the reason why I leave two hours
early is because I got to drive far I
drive for about an hour and a half and
then I just wait and I guess I see if I
can guess when the clock turns midnight
but I but I I I I don't ever really know
if I can because I wait even longer than
that I my my whole my my thing is I
don't want to know when the new year
starts it it's too stressful I when I'm
at at a party even to get together and
people or even just like a few people
around and I see people nine eight dude
that's so I'm never more anxious than
that I I tell you right now I'm never
more anxious than someone going
hey you know think about that any other
time during the year you you would be so
alarmed so just because it's that time
and we know that that's the year dude
I'm too I I I just and I'm not talking
about explosions or bombs or things that
are going off I I don't want anything to
be timed like that it makes me so
anxious bro I I hate
it they don't even do the re they don't
even say the whole numbers you know four
[Applause]
three right sorry I have to save all the
continent to scream out Happy New
Year I I I I
just it makes me anxious it really
genuinely does I want to be or the [__]
would be to be asleep before the that CU
that's something that dads do now that
I'm a dad I got two kids I bet I could
probably pull that one off just sleep
through the New Year [__] yeah
dude just wake up at 3:00 a.m. to go pee
oh it's already 2025 oh sh all right
cool
man
yeah I tried to watch uh Santa the Santa
Claus I guess there's a new one the
Santa
Clauses with uh
Tim what's his name Allen and then he
was it it was so bad I had to turn it
off I wanted to watch it
cuz Gabriel uh
fluffies in it and I like him you know I
didn't get to his part though it just
like he was on the sleigh and then he
had like a
um an elf that was black and gay which
is fine but it's
like you know if you're going to be
inclusive like don't make the black gay
guy an elf you know give him a real
grown-up part right because you're kind
of still being racist in a way make
Santa black and gay
and then make the elf Tim Allen right
and
so she's like ho ho ho [__] and um but
Santa was like but Santa was like uh cow
he goes crawler
me and and which is just doesn't sound
at all it doesn't roll off the tongue
you know some writer you know in
Hollywood just like this will be good he
says crwler me and the gay black elf
goes and he shoots out a crawler donut W
he's on the sleigh and Tim Allen whizzes
by and just Catch catches it with his
mouth it's done so poorly it looks so
bad right and but I don't even mean the
CGI of it it's just like the whole idea
and the way it's shot it's so it's so
[__] bad and I go I got to turn this
off I tried to watch it with
Calvin I turned this off and
um what I want to know is look Tim
Allen's the [__] he's done so
much I I don't I don't I guess these
guys get bored I I I just I'll never
understand because Tim all's worth like
half a billion dollars
right he he he's got um what do you call
it Santa Claus money he's got home
improvement
money I don't get this [__]
man when I make my first cool Billy I'm
done toy story bro when I at my first
cool Billy I'm done dude when I at my
first
cool 50
mil my first
cool what is a crawler anyway how do you
even spell it donut how do you spell
that CR crawler it's a crawler I thought
it was a crawler it's a crawler
crawler it's Cru
crawler all right so here's the deal
dude Donuts are the [__] I don't eat
donuts I'm going to [__] piss people
off crispy creams you're out it's too
sweet you're out I get a glazed donut
from Crispy Cream I have diabetes
immediately okay Crispy Cream you're out
and I don't Duncan Donuts you're in dude
you're you're involved in the
conversation okay I love Dunkin' Donuts
there are great donuts and then there
are piss poor horrible Donuts the best
donuts are the regular Donuts that they
figured out how to make centuries ago
when you make donuts with things like
Captain Crunch on them and all the
sprinkles and [__] and you're a [__]
actual 30-year-old that eats them you're
crazy my son might think that's a good
idea those kinds of donuts are
absolutely Grand bankable terrible I
can't
eat any also okay so these are the best
Donuts
glazed sugar with the regular shits or
the twisty ones but also I don't I just
the circles are fine chocolate glazed
chocolate hell yeah dude now we're
banging now we're talking about the gra
here here look let's look at
the here here here here here here top 10
Donuts no I don't want the dut
shops top 10 Donuts I
want now see they they they here we go
best donuts in
La I they're going to give me the shops
and see that's what pisses me right
off yep these look [__] good dude but
the highend donut spots like look at
this this has what's it called in it
blinkies dut this place has uh uh what's
the Fred Flintstone uh
cereal what is is the cereal
crispy what the [__] are they called
Cocoa Krispies no the other
ones Fruity Pebbles hell yeah we thought
about them Coco PE and cocoa but they
have Fruity Pebbles on it dude you know
where I go to I go to that place um what
is it uh
phuts and they're [__] they have they
do have vegan Donuts I I don't get those
I don't think actually I don't even know
how to get I go there those are great
because they're not as sweet because
they have to be because they're not
they're a better version for you than
the other Donuts those are the [__] dude
and I get the blueberry ones ones and oh
are you kidding me dude I get the
blueberry ones and I go are you serious
I get the blueberry ones and I go like
this maybe I could just be addicted to
these instead of
dinkin
donuts come on into dinkin Donuts
dude
um crawlers you know
Cronut Benet
dude John Benet
ramsy Benet are crazy they should have
changed the name when John B Ramsey got
all
killed benay
it's all
right look at these [__] things
Cronut beignet profiterol n get out of
here with that [__] croen Bush I mean
you know what the [__] are those
bearclaw then there's just cream Fritter
never had one eair get out of here
oldfashioned dut hell yeah dude hell
yeah I'm
oldfashioned churro is fine I guess boss
oh the cream in the no oh bro I don't
need Jizz In My Mouth for real when you
how about when you bite a dut you don't
know it's cream and then cream happens
in your mouth how gay does it feel for
real I'm being serious I'm not and I'm
not homophobic I love gays dude I'll
[__] love them I love gay people
straight up I wish more we're in my
house right now but when you bite into a
doughnut and you think straight up it's
not cream and then just jizz pops off in
your mouth and fills it up you go oh oh
I have to you know what the day is over
I got to go to sleep now I got to go to
sleep I got to go to sleep now when you
when you crunch into a beautiful
looking chocolate covered doughnut that
seems like it's just going to be regular
and Airy inside and all of a sudden top
jizz just splurts inside your mouth you
go oh even though you only eat donuts in
the morning the day is over and got to
go to sleep now
I can't first of all I don't like the
taste of the jiz in it second of
all it's too much put a little bit bro
when those burst in your mouth I go this
isn't a doughnut anymore first of all
duts are cake let's get let's not get it
twisted when you put more cake in the
dut and have it jizz up inside you
raw right oh it J when you and you go H
and you go oh it [__] inside me raw
going to bed guys
night guys what is it it's [__] 700
a.m. you just got to work oh dude you
must have bit into a Boston creamfield
oh I didn't no oh dude he's all right
dude take the day off we'll count it is
a sick
day then you wake up [__] just a
whole full 23 hours later and you go I
better just eat the [__] crawlers
now when you that and that's people's
favorite donut too right when your
favorite dut let me tell you something
when your favorite dut is a one that has
a cream fil in it bro it might as well
be its own thing that's the thing you
shouldn't be able to go to a dut shop
this is why I would be so unsuccessful
if I did anything but comedy because I
would just I would be like why would I
want the ones with the cream in it man
I'm so [__] insane I want the circle
ones it's bad enough we got the mini
ones but we're not going to throw the
extra dll away so just have the [__]
mini one the mini ones are the [__]
right
the bite size God chocolate glazed
donuts are forget when I was a kid and
you would get that chocolate glaze Donut
oh dude I would
just cupcakes are [__] cake is
[__] Donuts are where it's at
cookies are where it's at brownies where
it's at if they're not high ftin I don't
like the I just like regular
[__] anyway dude we're getting Way Off
Track I did not mean to talk about
Donuts so much in this freaking podcast
wait people thought Snoop
Dogg stop smoking
weed uh Snoop Dogg is in quitting
cannabis here's why he's giving up smoke
what the [__] is
this this is a
commercial made headlines when he
announced he was giving up smoke Snoop
Dog isn't giving up any kind of smoke
say what is this
[__]
um man I remember I did that roast with
Snoop
Dog his roast was they cut it out a lot
of it but oh my God giving up smoke but
it's not what you think all right Snoop
Dogg made headlines when he announced on
social media he quote decided to give up
smoke hm odd way to announce that you're
going to stop smoking weed like every
assumed right even Meek milchin in yeah
Meek said after speaking with his doctor
he was going to stop smoking too he also
saided the quote many chemicals found in
newer strains of marijuana anyways turns
out that the smoke Snoop was planning to
give up had nothing to do all right man
get to it Snoop smoke is kind of your
whole thing but I'm done with it done
with the coughing and my clothes
smelling all sticky icky I'm going
smokeless solo sto fix fire they take
out the smoke yeah SOLO stoves are
advertised as smokeless fire pits and
Snoop now has a line with them the
initial bundle includes a pit designed
by Snoop and other accessories
separately Snoop also announced that
he's going to reissue his iconic album
doggy style and given the news of this
new brand deal dude how old is Snoop Dog
how this guy is incredible so he he has
a stove that's kind of a cool a cool
smokeless fire pit
[__] W how old is he Snoop Dog
age 52 bro he's still
young I have to [__] live my whole
life with Snoop Dogg around you ever
think about that doesn't that s snoop's
fine I'm but like I have to I have to
have to I'm born in the time that the
Kardashians are and like I don't hate
the Kardashians like it's just I have to
hear about them at least twice a week
for the rest of my life you ever think
about that like that's just what your
life all our lives you listen to this
podcast you know who the Kardashians are
you have to hear about them now for the
if you're my age or if you're a little
younger or older if you're like six you
won't they'll die and you'll have like a
half your life where you probably don't
have to hear about them dude doesn't
that
suck the only hope that we have to not
hear about the Kardashian is if they all
get exploded in their house say you hate
somebody that's really Kanye West right
you have to hear about him the rest of
your
life that sucks
bro I guess it's cool that we went many
years without knowing like I went my
first 20 years without knowing who they
were you
know anyway that's that's cool that's it
I don't know you guys um I appreciate
you let maybe look one of these
um deserved scales or what wait hold oh
man I have been watching these public
freakouts Extreme Car
Wash
red light bro come on dude don't take
that red light don't not take the red
light bro there's a cop right behind us
he's going to get hit oh
[__] you're going to hit
someone by the way what does it mean
don't take that red
light don't take it go go go go forward
go is he going to get hit dude go go
go oh the [__] I had to start over
because I had to sign in God damn it
oh [__] so
Mexican oh [__]
dog [__] I mean so Mexican chich and
Chong in here oh [__] hey so Mexican D I
love it dude hey bro bro bro go forward
oh what the [__] oh
my dude it's coming to the air V that is
crazy oh they're going to see this
video wow oh I wish I knew those guys
those guys seem so funny
broo oh
[Music]
[__] oh [__] hey hey bro bro bro go
forward oh what the [__] oh my oh
no bro God oh no way he dude so funny
wow I love that
one wow I love that
one oh
no when the cool mom what's it
say it's so great that this takes so
long to go cool
Mom
oh oh no pull forward
dude
[Music]
oh my God
bro
o imagine that's your mom
bro oh God here let's do one more here
let's do this last one here or the crazy
video Drunk wait no come on get out of
here get out of
here
dude okay here we go drive into bug
drunk driving lit bug breaks his own
window
no oh this
[__] the
glove dude
how how do you not look at
how the reaction dude the re the
reaction is f nomenal
bro what a the realest reaction that's
ever happened the realest reaction how
does he not know when the windows
open the [__] the really IST reaction
this reaction keeps the G dude why is he
driving with a batter's glove
on this whole thing is the whitest thing
ever the ar ar sunglasses does he have a
a a strap
beard the
guy posted it you know all right all
right well thank you for listening that
is uh the episode go to if you want to
watch the rest of the episode not just
the uh one on YouTube you want to watch
the rest of it go to patreon.com
christalia you can watch the rest of the
episode and then also you can also watch
all of the other episodes that we've
done we do one a month for only patreon
and there's like there's well over 30
now so you can go there get that for uh
just six bucks go watch 30 all 30 more
30 30 or more of them right now um
appreciate you and you're also
supporting the show uh and we love you
for it you keep the show going without
you the show wouldn't exist so thank you
um appreciate you guys a lot and go see
uh go to go to my special go get my
special at chris.com check that out I
work really hard on that and uh I'd love
for you to see it thanks a lot guys
[Music]
bye-bye